veamos un reto que te ayudará a mejorar
tu conocimiento sobre los cuerpos y
figuras geométricas así que corre por
lápiz y papel pausa el vídeo y reinicia
lo cuando los tengas aquí te espero
ok para este reto te voy a ir
presentando unas imágenes y tendrás que
dibujar todas las figuras geométricas
que encuentres al final veremos cómo te
fue si quieres puedes detener el vídeo
para observar mejor cada imagen listo
comenzamos primer nivel observa la
imagen
vamos con la que sigue
segundo nivel seguimos avanzando
la imagen que sigue
vamos por una imagen más
tercer nivel
por mucha atención porque esta es la
última imagen
muy bien ahora revisemos cómo nos fue
las formas o cuerpos geométricos que
debimos haber descubierto son las
siguientes
rectángulos en la hoja de papel en el
envase de leche y en el edificio
cuadrados en la base de la leche y en
las ventanas del edificio triángulos en
la parte superior del envase de leche en
el techo del edificio
círculos en la forma del plato en la
base de la lata del jugó en la bola de
helado y en el techo del edificio
perfecto espero que hayas encontrado
todas las figuras te invito a que reces
a tus amigos y que juntos dibujen las
figuras y formas geométricas de todo lo
que hay a su alrededor